je passe quoi l'adresse je sais pas mais
ces longues files et on verra bien
waouh
elle doit être cher cette porte le
studio qui vous a offert shrek kung fu
panda et madagascar salut je suis
georges luz et voici mon meilleur pote
are all gonna fabrique des bd et on
essaie d'y acquérir cette aune qu'il du
bonhomme là ces messieurs chouchou ces
principes le plus nul de la terre depuis
le jour où vous êtes entré dans cette
école vous l'avez cessiez de faire de
mauvaise farce
certaines ont dû être hyper dur à
préparer la whey celle du tigre celle
des tigres trop bien je vous avais
prévenu qu'un jour je vous aurais et les
bris la décision de vous mettre dans des
classes se bat j'avais détruire votre
métier lâcher ce stylo monsieur chanson
oui vous hypnotise
chaque fois que je claquerait des doigts
vous devrez oublieras n'osant et
maintenant vous êtes nos vendeurs si les
cabinets super slim
non honnêtement je pensais pas que ça
marcherait venez d'anti tacoli il faut
l'arrêter
pourquoi effectivement il faudrait
arrêter leurs plus belles créations
capital super slip
vous pouvez pas réellement volé je
m'envole tenue entre eux
les super g va devenir plus leur plus
gros problème
[Musique]
tiré d'un livre mondialement connu
bonjour les enfants tu fais pas très
nombreux professeurs très cool pas un
terreau mian visibles ont un projet
délicat
y'a pas de soucis et cacher ça s'est su
richert
quand on voit toutes à la suite comme ça
ça fait l'effet de ouf
en bon gars vous êtes s'emprisonner à
l'intérieur d'une boîte invisible tu
crois que c'est réglo d'être mort de
rire là oui et non je vais vous sortir
de l'eau mais surtout